[Música]
extranjero
[Música] está
bien,
creo que es muy importante que
salgamos a protestar hoy y mostremos
apoyo de cualquier manera que podamos para nuestros
indígenas australianos, en realidad es el
día 85 de luto este año, por lo que nuestros
indígenas australianos han estado
protestando por esto durante 85 años. están
dispuestos a considerar una voz con
negociaciones de tratados tiene que ser un
reconocimiento de soberanía
entonces tiene que haber un tratado y luego
podemos hablar de voz y todo eso
tiene que tomar más tiempo del que el
gobierno quiere para el
tiempo de consulta la gente necesita pensar seriamente
en cómo va a verse lo están
apurando no van a
lograr los objetivos de hacer la paz
en este país
discúlpenme
extranjero